The Joe Rogan experience.
So you made a movie about the story that you told on the podcast about a
guy who pretended that he was from Yale and you,
and then he found out later in your relationship that he was not,
and he was completely full of.
All that story on your podcast couple years ago.
And I was trying to think if that was the first time I'd ever been on your
podcast in this iteration, like as the huge Joe Rogan experience podcast.
And I couldn't remember if I'd been on it before, prior to.
That. I think you had. I think.
So too, but I think I was like,
that would be the perfect book end to this story because the first time I told
it in its totality was here and then here I am and I've
made this movie it's.
It's such a crazy story. Yeah. The fact that the guy that,
that really was what he was doing,
he was just completely lying about his background and who he was. And,
but it worked for a little while.
Well, you know, sorry.
I remember when I told the story and of course the feedback's all like.
No [inaudible].
And so I was just like, okay,
I gotta be careful in the way that I parse out this narrative. And my answer is,
you know, there's red flags that we're taught to think about. You know,
you're walking down the street in New York city and someone gives you a look,
you got red flags, right. You're at a, um, you're doing a business deal.
There's red flags in a relationship, you know, because of music and TV,
we're all thought to think about cheating, right. And lying in that way.
I meet you randomly. And in the first five minutes, I'm like,
where'd you go to school? What do you do? I wouldn't,
I don't want to be the kind of person that has a radar up because these weren't
lies. Like I'm the king of Spain. I have a fleet of yachts at my disposal.
It was like, I went to Yale, just like my cousin did. And I do hedge funds,
like, okay, normal, normal. And that's how these kind of people get by.
And so.
These weren't things on a plane, right?
An airplane, an airplane as if there's a different, like just a grassy plane,
specifically an airplane.
We're headed into a gig. He was sitting next to you.
Um, and over Thanksgiving, I was just on my family.
Some of them were on the east coast. And I, my big thing as a con,
like I always, my whole career, I spend the money on the travel.
Like that's a great investment,
like buy that first class ticket when you travel so much, I'm like,
that's where the money goes.
And you're usually sitting next to someone who looks like your dad in first
class. It's seldom that I, and this was, I was probably 29 at the time,
28, 29, seldom. You're sitting next to someone around your age, you know,
and here's a guy.
And so we just start talking because we're this around the same age. Um,
and that, and we just got along super. He was funny. He was dorky, but smart,
like just a cool guy. And I,
he had a girlfriend and I had a boy picking me up at the airport.
And I think we exchanged, like Twitter handles like this.
Wasn't like a salacious, like, give me your details. And I was like,
if you and your girlfriend ever want to come to a show, you know,
you're a comic, you get it. Like comedy store.
I can get paid the same way either way. So come on down to the store,
but we became friends. And what made it easy was when your comic,
you keep such odd hours,
like how many times have you eaten dinner at like one in the morning?
And you're like a duo for protein later.
At night, but I usually don't eat at night. All right, cool.
I intermittent fast too. That's what I do.
On it.
Uh.
But my voice on it.
I think it's just my generic beefy guy. Okay. That could be you.
It could be me.
Bro. What you don't understand is that it's just a structure within a democracy,
which is a manmade construct. Whoa.
That's good. It's not bad. It's not bad. It's not bad. I'd have to, I'd have to.
It's a pro talk. That's like bro, bro politics, bro. Intelligent talk. Yeah.
So what did this guy actually do? What was his actual job?
He worked at a hedge fund. Um,
and I mean, who checks?
That would a person who works at a hedge fund,
know the difference between a club headliner and a theater headliner.
Like there's less like why w okay.
That sounds really boring and whatever I get that that's with numbers and,
and.
Money, but he went to a college. You went to.
All college. Just not that one.
Right. That's.
What I found out way later.
Working at a hedge fund. Yeah. But.
I think it was like super low level. Like he made it like, oh,
I'm starting my own business. And you know, you're 29 years old.
You're sitting in a first-class seat and you're dressed like a dork.
And you're talking a bit, why wouldn't, I believe you,
I've plenty of friends who are successful at things other than standup and most,
you know?
Well, my point was that if he just was himself and he just said,
I'm working at a hedge fund and was the same guy, just as funny, probably.
That is the you completely keyed in on it.
The whole takeaway from the movie is all the things that he didn't lie about
were the things that I actually valued the most. He was,
you cannot fake intelligence. You cannot fake sense of humor. Right?
You cannot fake wit. Right.
And he had those, he had those.
Things. He was unattractive,
which is probably a big source of his insecurity and whatever else society put
on him.
But that was the sad part was I wasn't VAT impressed by going to a
good school and having a job I've never heard of, you just said, like,
I went to this regular school and I do this.
I still would have said come to the comedy store. I still would have had drinks.
So that's a, it's not a shame. Cause I,
I really am into my husband and the way that that worked out.
But that's the weird,
the sad part is that we put rather than just be good at something,
someone just like lied and built a whole world around it.
Have you kept in touch in touch with her gone?
Oh yeah. We hang out all the time. No. Oh my God.
No, but I mean, no, I mean, he's never reached out and said, Hey,
I heard that story. No, nothing.
I, uh.
No. How long did you date him for.
Only three months. We were friends for a full year,
which is why it kind of, it, you don't question your friends as much.
Right. And here's someone that always showed up the dudes in my group.
Like all the comics that you know, that I'm friends, like, they've all met him.
Like we go out drinking and my schedule is so weird. So I'd be like,
I need to get dinner at like 11. He'd be down for it. I was like, great.
This has got a malleable schedule. And we were friends for that year.
I have best friends in LA and I've been to their apartment twice right.
In 15 years. So you're not, um,
checking on things because I just take it at face value where you live and stuff
like that. And to be honest, the closer we became his friends, the more he like,
he was like, look, I really like you. And we would always, you know,
you're in your twenties. So you're going out drinking.
I never wanted to go to his house.
Like he would meet me at my condo and we would go,
or my friends would come over because I was like,
there's no reason if you know that if I know you like me and I don't like you,
there's no reason for me to go to your house.
Like you want to keep on neutral territory. It's not,
I'm not afraid of my physical safety, but in terms of messaging,
I think that's a little like, I don't like you,
but I'll get drunk and hang out in your room. We're not doing that.
I got a house smart. It was a bar. Right. Right.
And I was very honest the whole time. I'm like, I'm just not there yet.
And I do go on dates and.
Though, sorry. So you're saying there's a chance.
Uh, that was, I think I was just thinking about,
so you're saying there's a chance, which is how guys think.
But I was very honest in, in being like, look, I was a.
Chance. Cause he wound up doing together with him.
Yeah. But I didn't see it that way. That's like.
Ah, but you get.
It. I mean, that's,
you're talking about an eventuality that no one could foresee because I was
dating other people. Right, right. He, consistency was key. Uh, well actually.
Hang out in that.
Friend zone, I hear that. And I would always say,
I'm not into you. In fact, I'm going on a date tonight. But by the way, if you,
if you can't handle that and you don't want to be my friend, that's okay.
I would give him these out. Right. And the truth is I wasn't into him.
We were very closest friends. And then one day he told me his mom had cancer.
Right. So as a human and as a woman, you know,
like there's a vulnerability that he cried probably thinking about,
he's probably crying about what a good liar he is. But like.
Mom didn't really have cancer. Nope. Yeah. That's, what's up. I remember this.
And I forgot her part of it. I met her. We had just so like, you know,
my heart opened up and you can't, as a woman, you can become,
this is my big thing.
You can become attracted to a man who are physically not attracted to because of
personality men. It doesn't work. Joe.
You've never been like that girl is a wart hog,
but it turns out she's really funny. So I do want to put my mouth on hers.
Like you've never in your life been like bushy got a great personality,
but girls do, it's just, we're cerebral. You know? And men are very visual.
And so it was all the kindness. How smart, how funny all this stuff,
mama got cancer. I'm like, oh my God, I need to be there for this person.
Who's been nothing.
But kind to me as a human and my heart opened up whatever.
And I met her, it was around the holidays. And so we, uh, yeah,
because we met in November and this was,
I remember I was going like Christmas craft shopping. And uh,
we met at like a craft store and she was there and I'd
never, you know, she has cancer. And he said, she's very sick.
So I didn't want to be in delicate. I didn't want to be like, how'd your cancer,
Susan? You know? So I remember asking her like, how are you feeling?
And of course this woman's like feeling fine. Why have you heard otherwise?
Oh.
God. And we only talked for like a half hour, you know?
And I remember at the time thinking like, oh, this is a guy that I really like,
and I, if she's going to die, I want her to know that her,
her son is with someone. Who's kind. I remember thinking that,
wow.
Because.
That's so heavy and it's so heavy.
And I didn't find out that she didn't have the cancer until after I realized all
the lies and I had broken her off,
I ran into some mutual friends and I was like, I just, you know, he's a loser,
I guess.
Literally insane. That's an insane person.
He's an insane person. But also the story is so insane.
And you still have to tread lightly as a woman because people find fault,
no matter what you do. Like, I remember someone saying like, well,
you're a gold Digger. And I was like, how's that? Now?
Like I've made a bunch of my own money since I was like, twenty-five no,
but it opened my eyes up to the perception just of when you tell a story,
that's so honest, the feedback that you get, and you're like, okay,
let me control this narrative.
So that's why in the movie, she's not some struggle.
I put her as like a Mo mostly successful to show like this doesn't like she
needed anything. Right. And a lot of articles were like, she was so strong.
It's like, no, no, she just didn't wake up and die.
I wonder what other lies that guy.
Cause that's not a guy who's done that for the first time.
Like if someone's lying about their mom having cancer, oh my God.
It's such a crazy lie, such.
Bad karma.
Bad energy to go through life like that.
It's like the momentum of all those lies must be like inescapable.
Like how does one stop and become an honest person when you're lying about that
many things and intimate things like your mother,
the person who gave life to you,
you're lying and saying that she has cancer. So that a global like you more,
it's really insane. Super beta. And it's well, it's, it's a pattern.
That's a strange pattern because like what makes people lie? You know.
Feeling insufficient, you know,
feeling that you and this is for better, for worse.
We hold men to a certain standard in our society.
I'm not excusing this behavior. I'm just saying, you know,
men who don't want to be sensitive or don't want to cry or are afraid to show
vulnerability because we have this like macho archetype.
Most don't actually expect that. And they want you to be yourself and open up.
And, but we do just, as we put things on women,
we do put things on men and we don't have conversations about that.
The difference is men don't realize like, oh, you gotta do is go out.
I talk about this on stage. And like, just be good at something.
And there will be a girl who will like ride or die with you in your Toyota
passenger seat. Like that's my Navy.
He's the best mustache grower like B all these comics. And we're talking about,
they all funny guys. So you can just be funny. You don't have to be attractive.
You could just be kind. You could just be good at like magic the gathering.
There's a girl. That's cool that,
but some people just think if I posture and I lie,
I'll get the kind of girl I deserve.
Don't you think it's also that kind of like financial world,
like the financial world is very much about filled associate pass.
There's a lot of that. Sure. But it's all about like,
what kind of car do you drive? What kind of watch do you have? Where is your,
where's your house? And you know, what, how much money are you making?
How much did you make last year? What's your, what's your end goal?
Archetypes like that patina of a person, right?
Like you have to be the what's his name and American psycho, Patrick, Patrick,
Patrick Bateman. Having to be that.
And the whole movie is about that expectation of the business card,
things like that. I mean, I didn't include,
he told me he was in skull and bones. Oh, Christ.
And I remember thinking like, I don't know, that's a pretty,
that's a pretty big secret people. And he invited me, he was like,
I'm going to London for like a reunion, like an event. Do you want to come?
And I was like, sort of, but I do need my own room. Like,
I'm not going to share a room with you.
And then of course he ended up not going, of course,
but there things where they're so out of my room,
like I am not in skull and bones and it seems so foreign.
So you fit the bill, I guess you could be.
I think wouldn't you think he'd be more successful if wasn't calling bones?
Isn't that one of those things where you're connected to all those?
Well, how do you gauge how successful someone is by their car?
Because he drove a really nice car and I never saw his house and he dressed well
and spoke. Like.
He thought he was very successful.
He presented as a kid that I went to school with.
Obviously it was kind of doing well, if he did work for a hedge fund, right.
Anyone can, they will let almost anyone sign a lease.
Car. What kind.
Of car was it? It was like an Audi.
I couldn't tell you what kind of a nice car it's in it. Yeah.
So doing pretty good, I guess.
So, but I also like, wasn't so impressed. Like I had my.
Own condo give a. Anyway. If a guy had a Porsche and he lived in a.
My husband drives a Mazda and I drive a Honda civic hybrid that I,
I want to last comic standing. You still have.
To reflect, you still.
Have the love it.
Wow. Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Jerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan.